in chemistry it's important to
distinguish between thermodynamics and
kinetics
for example if we think about the
conversion of carbon as a solid in the
diamond form to carbon as a solid in the
graphite form thermodynamics tells us
what will happen will this conversion
happen at a specific temperature whereas
kinetics tells us when the conversion
could happen
let's start with thermodynamics we can
calculate if this conversion will happen
at room temperature of 25 degrees
celsius by calculating the standard
change in free energy for this reaction
at that temperature
to calculate the standard change in free
energy for this reaction we need to know
the standard change in free energy of
formation of the products and from that
we subtract the standard change in free
energy of formation of the reactants
for this conversion our product is
carbon in the graphite form and because
carbon in the graphite form is the most
stable elemental form of carbon at a
pressure of one atmosphere the standard
change in free energy of formation of
carbon in the graphite form is equal to
zero next we think about our reactant
which is carbon in the form of diamond
the standard change in free energy of
formation of carbon in the diamond form
is 2.84 kilojoules per mole looking at
our balanced equation for this
conversion we're converting one mole of
diamond into one mole of graphite since
there's a one as a coefficient in front
of diamond we multiply the standard
change in free energy of formation of
diamond by one mole of diamond
moles cancel and we get negative 2.84
kilojoules as the standard change in
free energy for this reaction
instead of kilojoules the units could
have been written as kilojoules per mole
of reaction
because there's one mole of carbon in
the diamond form for how the balanced
equation is written we could write a
conversion factor of one mole of carbon
in the diamond form per mole of reaction
and because the standard change in free
energy of formation of diamond is equal
to 2.84 kilojoules per mole of diamond
moles of diamond would cancel out and
give kilojoules per mole of reaction as
the units
because the standard change in free
energy for this reaction is negative we
know that the conversion of diamond into
graphite at 25 degrees celsius is
thermodynamically favorable
next let's think about the kinetics of
this reaction if we look at the
structure of diamond each carbon atom is
covalently bonded to four other carbons
for example this carbon right here is
bonded to four other carbon atoms and a
tetrahedral geometry around this central
carbon atom graphite has a very
different structure in graphite carbon
atoms form covalently bonded layers or
sheets and these layers or sheets are
held together by london dispersion
forces
so in order to convert diamond into
graphite we would have to break a lot of
carbon-carbon bonds and that would take
a lot of energy
since it takes a lot of energy to break
the carbon-carbon bonds and diamond if
we look at the energy profile for this
reaction
this reaction would have a very high
activation energy symbolized by ea
and the higher the activation energy for
the reaction the slower the rate of the
reaction
at room temperature it's estimated this
reaction could take billions of years
therefore we would say this reaction is
kinetically unfavorable
finally let's summarize what we've
learned about the conversion of diamond
into graphite thermodynamics answers the
question will the reaction go and the
answer to that question is yes at room
temperature diamond will convert into
graphite because delta g naught for the
reaction was negative kinetics answers
the question how long will it take and
the answer to that question is it would
take billions of years for diamond to
turn into graphite at room temperature
the reason why the reaction is so slow
is because of the extremely high
activation energy so even though the
reaction is thermodynamically favorable
at room temperature because the reaction
is so slow the reaction is kinetically
unfavored and for all practical purposes
the reaction doesn't happen